la cartouche
ça raconte l'histoire de deux collectionneur de jeux vidéos
qui vont découvrir le saint graal, c'est-à-dire
la cartouche qui a le plus de valeur au monde
le prototype du tout premier Mario
20 000 balles, tu vois ce que je veux dire
c'est le premier jour de la cartouche, tournage de la cartouche
7 jours de tournage
c'est le plus long tournage de ma vie, il m'a fallu a peu près
8 mois pour trouver le temps, le timing, les gens pour le faire
d'ailleurs, je voulais tourner l'été quand il faisait beau
mais ça a été tourné l'hiver quand il faisait froid
Le froid ça ne va pas du tout comme vous le remarquez
mais c'est ma faute, c'est moi qu'est écrit dans le script qu'il avait des pantoufles Mario
c'est au moment où je regardais des Youtubers
sur le net, qui collectionnent justement
des jeux rétros et vont faire des vides-greniers
et ils achètent pour vraiment pas cher
des jeux rétros qui ont pas mal de valeurs
ça existe,
je me rappel d'un Youtuber qui faisait ça en duo avec un pote qui avait fait
une vidéo, "je suis plus pote
avec untel"
c'est plus mon pote, moi je fais mes vidéos tout seul
et dans ma tête je me suis dis "mais pourquoi ils sont plus potes"
on avait pas les raisons
Et donc en fait, mon cerveau a pas pu s'empêcher
d'imaginer une histoire totalement folle
c'est comme ça que j'ai eu l'idée de la cartouche
et ensuite y'a tous les personnages qui se sont greffés à ça
"Salut les puceaux"
J'ai flippé sa race
"-Euh Alice?
-Laisse moi! Ah oui?"
Ah mon personnage il a que des fous rire
"Tes dans ta piaule qui pue avec tes jeux vidéos de merde
Vous êtes vraiment débiles"
"Ouvrez  les serrure, ça sent le cul de vieux!"
En tout cas pour le cast, j'ai eu les gens que je voulais
je voulais absolument Alison pour faire Tiphaine
je voulais Justine pour faire Cathy
Frédérique, joueur du grenier pour faire le vendeur
'Fin vraiment j'ai eu le casting que je voulais
la geekette, qu'est attirée par moi
-C'est plus de l'attirance, c'est un besoin
-C'est un besoin de moi
Quand on crée des perso
il faut qu'ils aient une tête, une voix, des habits
tout ça doit être particuliers en fait
donc c'était normal pour moi qu'on se coupe les cheveux avec Ludo
jusqu'à preuve du contraire, ça, cette coupe de cheveux n'existe pas
On dirait que tu te les aient coupés toi même en fait
Mais je suis pas encore passé chez le coiffeur, c'est ma coupe normale ça en fait
Ah pardon désolé, ah excuse moi...
Je pensais que c'était la coiffeuse qui t'avait fait
Ah non non justement, j'y allais là j'y vais en fait
Je voulais vraiment que les personnages ils existent depuis très longtemps
depuis toujours ils se connaissent,
ils ont des problèmes dans la vie
mais ils ont aussi des trucs qu'ils aiment
enfin voilà, c'était, le background des personnages était super important pour moi
-Flo!
-Gabi
Bon lui on s'en fou
J'aime bien les passionnés, que ce soit ça ou des collectionneurs de timbres
ou des mecs qui adorent l'équitation
des mecs qui sont à font dans leur truc
et qui se donnent les moyens
qui se disent pas "que vont penser les gens?"
Non, qui se disent juste, "je le fait parce que c'est ce que j'aime
et ce en quoi je crois
du coup j'aimais beaucoup ça en fait
c'est pour ça que j'ai choisi d'ailleurs, ces deux mecs là, ces deux Youtubers
qui sont un peu dans leur délire
La chambre de Gaby a été construite,
les couleurs dans les objets qu'il y a
je voulais vraiment raconter le plus possible du personnage
c'est un papier peint d'enfant, ça veut dire
qu'il est potentiellement dans la même pièce
depuis 20 ans
Qu'on puisse voir des posters qu'il aime bien
des manges qu'il aime bien, des jeux qu'il aime bien
ou juste en regardant à gauche à droite
par les couleurs, les trucs, qu'on se disent "Ah bah d'accord ce perso là il veut dire ça"
Comme on est toute la journée dans un décor où y a une fausse fenêtre
avec de la lumière qui rentre, pour moi il fait jour
Sauf que là je viens de sortir, et regardes
il fait nuit!
Théo c'est celui qui a réalisé Technophobe
Cyp il vient me voir avec son scénario, avec ses idées
avec ses personnages, avec son univers
et moi mon rôle, ça va être de prendre tout ça
et de faire en sorte que ça soir le mieux possible retransmis à l'écran
Il est 9h36, là c'est le visage du seum
à cette heure ci je devrais être à l'avant-première de Star Wars
et je suis à ce tournage de merde! Putain!
Alors on a tourné 7 jours d'affilés
et 7 jours d'affilés sans faire de pauses, c'est chaud
mais on avait une super équipe, on se connait tous hyper bien
et on bosse ensemble depuis vachement longtemps
Y a Vlad le chef Op avec qui je travaille, on a dû faire quasiment
une centaine de vidéos ensemble du coup ça va hyper vite
et ça marche super bien
Yass c'est pareil, c'est un peu la maman du tournage
son rôle ça va être de faire en sorte que nos volontés tiennent dans la journée
Antoine, bon baaah
"FERMES TA GUEULE"
Moi c'est Antoine, je suis ingénieur du son
T'es dangereux mec!
Antoine arrêtes putain!
Tu gênes tout le monde, il casse les couilles!
C'est une fin de journée pour Ludo!
Il reste combien de temps de tournage pour les autres?
Oh 4h, 4-5h
À chaque fin de tournage on fait la petite danse de Ludo quoi
Ok les gars c'est une fin de journée merci à tous!
Premier jour on est hyper entrainés
on est dimanche on pète la forme
et à la fin c'est un peu triste
Troisième
Ah putain la p*te!
Mais Flo!
Ta gueule! j'ai jamais pu te blairer donc casse toi!
Tu pourras garder parce que je fais une propa différente
Ce tournage à lieu en période de Noël
et du coup pour faire rire un peu l'équipe, je me suis déguisé en père noël
"Joyeux Noël les amis! Vous voulez quoi pour Noël?"
Toi tu veux(...) c'est une maquilleuse, tu veux du maquillage?
J'aimerais une wii U
Pour toi j'ai une belle caméra et pour toi j'ai une belle perche de son
"-Tu veux quoi pour Noël?
-Je veux que tu fermes ta gueule par exemple
-C'est Ludo en fait!
-Ah! Ça va?"
J'ai eu énormément de chance
d'avoir Shigeru Miyamoto
et qui a bien voulu faire une séquence dans ce court métrage
donc Shigeru Miyamoto, c'est le créateur
de Mario
de Zelda
de Donkey Kong
enfin de tous ce qu'on aime bien dans les jeux vidéos
enfin en tout cas, tout ce que j'adore dans le jeu vidéo
je savais pas que quelqu'un comme ça, qui est super important pour moi
puisse jouer le jeu comme ça
qui est une star un peu partout dans le monde pour tous les gamers
et les non gamers même
j'estime avoir eu beaucoup, beaucoup, beaucoup de chance donc euh
c'est vraiment génial
On a eu un petit défi, c'est la tortue en 3D
c'est la première fois que j'ai de la 3D dans une de mes vidéos
J'avais adoré faire composé la musique
comme ça, ça raconte au mieux ce que je voulais raconter
donc c'était avec Nodey, c'est des musiques de Mario
ré-appropriées qui illustrent en fait l'aventure de la cartouche
Petite cerise sur la gâteau, le générique de fin par Bigflo & Oli
Donc énorme Big Up à vous les mecs
c'est vraiment génial, je leur aient pitché l'histoire
ils ont adoré, ils m'ont fait la musique comme ça dans la foulée
ils ont chanté ça, donc c'est vraiment super!
Bon ils le font beaucoup mieux que moi visiblement
Donc Big Up à vous les mecs franchement c'est super!
Y a un exercice qu'est de plus en plus ambitieux à chaque fois
de vouloir raconter des histoires de plus en plus longues
Moi j'ai adoré tourner ces 7 jours
tout le monde était à fond,
matin 6-7h, jusque le soir 22h parfois minuit parfois même plus
Cette vidéo c'était un peu un nouveau défi pour tous les postes
que ce soit au tournage ou au montage
D'arriver à consolider une histoire et de a faire marcher sur 20 minutes
c'est pas du tout le même exercice que sur 3 ou 4 minutes
Flo et Gabi, c'est des personnage que j'ai adoré imaginer
Ça serait dommage de s'arrêter en si bon chemin
donc moi je suis en train d'écrire Flo & Gabi version encore plus longue
parce que j'adore ces perso, j'espère que les gens aussi
Vous voulez les revoir ou pas?
"-Ouais on veut!
-Non on veut pas!"
D'accord
On vient de terminer la projection en avant-première au Grand Rex de la cartouche
C'était ouf, y avait tellement de monde!
C'est dingue d'avoir 2000 personnes qui regardent un même écran
Moi je suis très ému, très touché
et ça faisait plaisir d'avoir enfin les retours parce que j'attendais ça depuis plus d'un mois maintenant
Un gros Big U à tous ceux qui sont venus parce que les bénéfices vont à l'association cékedubonheur
qui soutient les enfants hospitalisés
Je voudrais juste remercier les internautes
Chers internautes , plus de 20 minutes de court métrage
si y a personne pour regarder bah c'est un peu dommage
et du coup ces gens là, rendent ça possible
Donc ça c'est vraiment génial et je vous dis à très vite sur internet
ou ailleurs
Ça glisse un peu